our daily wire has this report mayor
Eric Adams warned during a town hall
meeting on Wednesday evening that New
York City is on the verge of being
destroyed because of the large number of
illegal aliens that are being sent to
the democrat-controlled city Adam said
that never in his life has he
encountered a problem he was not able to
fix and bring to an end but that that
this illegal alien problem is one of
those problems he can't fix it he
doesn't know what to do he's helpless
let's watch a little bit of that meeting
and let me tell you something New
Yorkers
never in my life have I had I had a
problem
ended too
I don't see an ending to this
this issue
will destroy New York City
destroy New York City
we're getting 10
000 migrants a month
one time we were just getting Venezuela
now we can Ecuador now we can Russian
speaking coming through Mexico now we're
getting western Africa now we're getting
people from all over the globe have made
their minds up that they're going to
come through the southern part of the
border and come into New York City
and everyone is saying it's New York
City's problem
every community in this city is going to
be impacted we have a 12 billion dollar
deficit that we're going to have to cut
every service in this city is going to
be impacted
all of us
and so I say to you as I turn it over to
you this is some some of the most
educated
some of the most knowledgeable probably
more of my Commissioners and Deputy
Commissioners and Chiefs live in this
community
so as you ask me a question about
migrants
tell me what road you played
how many of you organized to stop what
they're doing to us
how many of you were part of the
movement to say we're seeing what this
mayor is trying to do and they're
destroying New York City
it's gonna come to your neighborhoods
all of us are going to be impacted by
this
I said it last year
yeah so this is uh
this is a good transition right from the
last topic to this one because this is
uh there's not there's not much we even
need to say about this this is a perfect
example of what we just talked about
um that's playing out right now in New
York City
of holding the left to their own
standards
um
you know mayor Adams
and you've you know other Democrats and
leftist leaders in New York
are speaking out about illegal immigrant
immigration and by the way in pretty
strident terms
he was talking about how it's gonna be
the destruction of the city
he's actually listing the places
Nicaragua you know he's listing the
places where the people are coming from
saying we don't want these people
um
it's the kind of thing that you hear
that rhetoric from Donald Trump
and it is it's racist it's xenophobic
it's extremist oh my God how could he
say that
um and now we're hearing it from Eric
Adams
and and he's not the only one Grand
Canyon University is an affordable
private Christian University that is
located in beautiful Phoenix Arizona and
is a vibrant and expansive campus ranked
top 20 in the country according to
niche.com praise for its culture of a
community giving and impact GCU
integrates the free market system and a
welcoming Christian worldview
Perspective into over 320 academic
programs with more than 260 programs
online as of March 2023. earn your
bachelor's Masters or doctoral degree
where you can engage with faculty and
connect with your own University
counselor who takes a personalized
approach for your success finds your
purpose at Grand Canyon University
private Christian affordable visit
gcu.edu that's gcu.edu Innovation
refunds has been helping small
businesses that qualify to get a
business payroll tax refund through the
employee retention credit or also known
as the ERC the ERC is a tax refund for
businesses that kept employees on
payroll for parts of 2020 and 2021. if
you own a business with more than five
employees you could have money waiting
to be claimed uh qualifying for the ERC
goes beyond sales decline if you're a
business face challenges to the growth
that it would have had without pandemic
government orders it may be eligible for
a substantial refund also Innovation
refunds independent tax attorneys can
help your business uh stay compliant
with IRS regulations and guidelines they
have hundreds of five-star trust pilot
and Google reviews they're also
accredited with the Better Business
Bureau and they won't charge you any
upfront fees or any money until you get
paid Innovation refunds does not provide
tax or legal advice they work with an
independent network of tax professionals
and they will share information with
them to evaluate and process your claims
go to innovationrefunds.com to determine
eligibility if you qualify you could be
on your way to receive money for your
business there's no upfront charge since
they don't get paid unless you get paid
go to innovationrefunds.com or dial
1-843 refunds that's
innovationrefunds.com or 1843 refunds
terms and conditions apply
my question is what where were you
you know when you had many other towns
for for decades in this country
especially towns down south towns around
the border border towns
um
they have been crying out about this
problem for decades
and where were you on that
does he have anything to say about that
at all did you care at all
or in fact did you go the other way
and when it was happening to other
people you said that uh you called it
xenophobia and said oh we have to be
welcoming
this is always how it goes on the left
they you know they have the these ideas
these alleged principles
um that are totally destructive and
insane but as long as they are insulated
from the consequences of these ideas as
long as they don't have to as long as
they can just propose them and then let
other people deal with the consequences
it's fine
same thing goes with defund the police
and have a relaxed attitude towards
crime
you know keep take violent criminals and
keep releasing them back out of this be
uh you know be generous and kind to
Violent criminals by refusing to punish
them for their evil Deeds
well as long as that's happening to
other people
and not to the leftist elites it's all
good but then the moment they start to
experience the consequences of that
their own neighborhoods start to become
unsafe now they they uh they begin using
the the same language and saying the
same things
that those dastardly racist
conservatives had been saying for years
before
and so that's exactly what's happening
now and he's and he's not wrong
this is the destruction of the of the
city there's no way you can't
you know there's there's just we live on
earth
uh and we are physical beings living in
a physical space with finite resources
and a finite amount of space you just it
just doesn't it doesn't work
you can't have an unending uh uh sort of
conveyor belt system
of dumping people into these places
and it's not like populations are
growing uh the old-fashioned way by
actual citizens having babies
no not that you're bringing in people
don't speak the language who aren't part
of the culture uh you're bringing in all
these people just dumping them there and
saying here you go you deal with it so
is it going to be the destruction of New
York City well absolutely I don't know
how I'm not sure how much is left to be
destroyed in that City but uh but yes
maybe we should say the continued
destruction of it
do I have any sympathy
for these people no
I have as much sympathy for them as they
had for uh all of the Border towns that
have been again crying out about this
for for decades if you'd like to see
what else I have to say you can access
my full show by going to dailywire.com
or by going to the Matt wall Show
Twitter page hope to see you there
Godspeed